hey guys my name is Jeff and welcome to
a day in the life of a 25 year old
proved engineer making 369k total comp
here in beautiful San Francisco I do my
daily stand-up and today is pretty chill
I'll be building seven web apps three
iOS apps 22 new JavaScript Frameworks a
custom compiler and a new operating
system kernel to build our first web app
we prompt the image AI for some design
files which look amazing I then proved
Captain formerly known as co-pilot to
bang out all the code for it it also
needs some content so we print the chat
AI to write some articles then for
e-commerce we generate some realistic
looking humans to model the products the
whole process took about four minutes so
now we can prove the accounting AI to
invoice the client for seventy thousand
dollars next I go to lunch on the perch
and have a pretentious salad which is so
yummy when I look down at the city below
I see a tent city filled with former
software Engineers which is so sad so I
prompt my AR glasses to remove them from
the scene uh Hey guys quick update I
just got laid off apparently the AI
learned how to print itself so I had to
downsize to this 2500 a month Studio